Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先和大家分享一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“通往经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由Lisa亲自提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你正打算成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南。欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》播客，我是Marianne Trent博士。
Thank you for being part of my world. Today I am joined by a lovely lady by the name of Dr. Deborah Kingston. And we first connected on social media. And it feels like we spent the last couple of years during the pandemic chatting and cheering each other on from the sidelines but today was the first time I've been able to speak with her you know one-to-one actually in real time and so it felt like a real treat. I really wanted to invite Deborah on for a variety of reasons because I think she has so much that so many of you will be able to resonate and connect with for a variety of reasons actually. So we are talking about coming to psychology slightly later than average, we are
感谢你走进我的世界。今天，我邀请到了一位可爱的女士，Deborah Kingston博士。我们最初是在社交媒体上认识的。感觉过去几年疫情期间，我们一直在场边聊天并互相打气，但今天是我第一次能与她进行真正的实时一对一交谈，这感觉真是一种享受。我非常想邀请Deborah来做客，原因有很多，因为我认为她所经历的一切，会让你们中的许多人产生共鸣并建立联系。所以，我们今天会谈到比平均年龄稍晚才进入心理学领域，
talking about dyslexia, we are talking about retraining, talking about working in tricky areas, managing tricky situations, mental ill health, you know, striving for being a psychologist whilst being a parent. We've got it all covered. It's a punchy, interesting, engaging episode. And I hope you will find it so useful. I will catch you on the other side. Hi, welcome along to this very special episode where I am joined by Dr. Deborah Kingston. Deborah, thank you for joining us. You're welcome. So you are a fellow clinical psychologist, but your route to clinical psychology may not look like you know a typical textbook assistant you know bit of a master's get on to doctorate and done. Would you like to tell people a little bit about your history? So when I was seven well let's start I
谈到阅读障碍，谈到转行，谈到在棘手的领域工作、处理棘手的情况、心理健康问题，以及如何在为人父母的同时努力成为一名心理学家。我们涵盖了所有内容。这是一期内容充实、有趣且引人入胜的节目。我希望你会觉得它非常有价值。稍后见。嗨，欢迎收听这期非常特别的节目，今天我的嘉宾是Deborah Kingston博士。Deborah，感谢你的加入。不客气。你也是一位临床心理学家，但你的临床心理学之路可能看起来并不像教科书上写的那样——比如读个硕士，考上博士，然后就完成了。你想和大家分享一下你的经历吗？好的，那我们从七岁开始说起，我
left school didn't have a GCSE no qualifications whatsoever was told I was a little bit sick and incapable of learning I think that's what one of the teachers said to my parents on a parents evening uh so uh I decided to join the RAF and that was my escapism from home and a life that really wasn't going to offer much opportunities so I joined the RAF age 17 and did quite well but it was during my RAF career I started to get educated and I was I worked really hard in the RAF and it was quite male dominated as you might imagine and it was really hard to kind of get ahead in a little bit of a way but I still I did really well I got promoted but I did accountancy so I was a catering accountant I dealt with a lot of numbers I dealt a catering accountant, I dealt with a lot
离开学校时连一个GCSE（中学毕业证书）都没有，没有任何资格证书。当时一位老师在家长会上对我父母说，我有点笨，没有学习能力。所以，我决定加入英国皇家空军（RAF），那是我的避风港，因为家里和当时的生活并没有给我提供太多机会。我17岁加入空军，表现还不错。正是在空军服役期间，我开始接受教育。我在空军工作非常努力，正如你所想象的，那里是一个男性主导的环境，想要出人头地非常困难，但我依然做得很好，还获得了晋升。我从事的是会计工作，是一名餐饮会计，我处理很多数字，我处理
of numbers, I dealt with a lot of people, I dealt with a lot of problems, because drinking and the RAF problems, people would always come to our boss, and I'd be like the gatekeeper to the boss to go talk to him, so I really had this flair for chatting to people, which I quite liked, and then in 2003 I became quite poorly with my mental health you know severely being bullied by a senior rank um who you know a lot of ganging up and stuff and the medics just wanted to medicate me and said antidepressants for the rest of your life you know there you go and it was during my time off sick I helped one of my friends do a psychology module for their social work course and it just felt like this was an easy thing to be doing for her like and she'd failed it so she'd come saying I failed this module I need to redo it I'm really struggling
很多数字，处理很多人，处理很多问题。因为酗酒和空军内部的问题，人们总是来找我们的老板，而我就像是老板的守门人，负责接待。所以我真的很有与人交谈的天赋，我也很喜欢这一点。后来在2003年，我的心理健康状况变得很糟糕，因为受到一位高级军官的严重欺凌，还有很多人的排挤。医生们只想给我开药，说我余生都要靠抗抑郁药度日。就在我病假期间，我帮一位朋友完成了她社会工作课程中的一个心理学模块，这对我来说感觉很容易。她当时挂科了，跑来跟我说：“我这门课挂了，我需要重修，我真的很挣扎。”
and I was like oh yeah but you know this one says this and this is really exciting and this is really good and it was like a real flair and I'd been doing a business degree so I was only two modules short of my BA in business studies and it was then she said have you thought about doing psychology so I called the Open University which again is not a conventional route for clinical psychologists and I joined the OU and I did my first course and luckily for me there was a lady that had left Cambridge University and moved up to the north of Scotland and had a little freehold and just wanted to do a little bit of teaching. On my second essay, she wrote at the bottom, come see me after lecture. This subject's not for you. She told me in that lecture, I was amazing last time. And I was like really conflicted.
我说：“哦，是吗？但这上面写着这个，这真的很令人兴奋，这真的很棒。”我发现自己真的很有天赋。当时我正在攻读商业学位，距离获得商业研究学士学位只差两个模块。就在那时，她说：“你有没有想过学习心理学？”于是我给开放大学（Open University）打了电话——这对于临床心理学家来说也不是一条常规路线——我加入了开放大学并完成了第一门课程。幸运的是，当时有一位女士从剑桥大学离开，搬到了苏格兰北部，拥有一个小小的永久产权房，只想做一点教学工作。在我的第二篇论文底部，她写道：“讲座结束后请来见我。这个科目不适合你。”她在讲座中告诉我，我上次表现得很棒。我当时感到非常矛盾。
And then when I went to see her at the end, she's no no Deborah I don't need to see you really good lecture again and I'm like right whoa you're confusing me now and I pulled these essays out and I said because you wrote this and she's like oh my god why don't you just tell me you were dyslexic and we could have sorted something out and I'm like do what and she's like how has nobody pointed out to you that you are severely dyslexic and I was like well they just said I was thick and she's like no you can clearly tell by your verbal ability you know your stuff but your written ability is just so poor uh we just need to get you some software and some techniques and that'll make a difference. And I went from basically going from a thank you for coming degree to 5% off for first.
后来讲座结束我去见她时，她说：“不，不，Deborah，我不是要见你，讲座表现很好。”我说：“等等，你现在把我搞糊涂了。”我拿出那些论文说：“因为你写了这个。”她说：“天哪，你为什么不早告诉我你有阅读障碍？我们可以解决这个问题。”我说：“什么？”她说：“怎么会没人指出你有严重的阅读障碍？”我说：“他们只是说我很笨。”她说：“不，从你的口头表达能力可以清楚地看出你很懂行，但你的书面表达能力太差了。我们只需要给你找些软件和技巧，那就会有所改变。”我的成绩从勉强及格直接提升到了离一等学位只差5%。
That's all I was at the end. And I got a high two on, really pleased with it. To be honest, I didn't even know that I was going to become a clinical psychologist because every single time we went to an open university thing, they said to you, if you're over 30, you're too old to become a clinical psychologist. If you're just doing your degree now and you're over 30, rule out becoming a clinical psychologist. Because clinical psychologists, you go A-levels, you go degree, you do some work experience,
最后我拿到了一个高二等学位，对此我非常满意。老实说，我当时甚至不知道自己会成为一名临床心理学家，因为每次我们参加开放大学的活动时，他们都会说：“如果你超过30岁，你就太老了，成不了临床心理学家。如果你现在才开始读学位而且超过30岁，就别想成为临床心理学家了。”因为临床心理学家的路线是：A-level，读学位，做一些工作经验，
you do a master's, you get an assistant post you go on the doctorate course that's your route and I was like oh god I'm I'm I'm not just over 30 I'm well into 30 I was like okay anyway I I then I started working an admin job in the nhs which i turned clinical a little bit i could do some audits and i did some clinical interviewing for the audit and then i published the audit because i wanted to try and then somebody said come get an assistant job but you need to like have some experience um and then i took the risk and left my full-time paid job with a mortgage and two kids and jumped ship to a six-month fixed term assistant psychology post with less money and I thought I've got to do it got to do it and then I started that job in chronic fatigue services a brilliant psychologist headed up that service
读硕士，获得助理职位，然后进入博士课程，这就是你的路线。我当时想：“天哪，我不仅超过30岁，而且已经30好几了。”我说：“好吧，不管怎样。”后来我在NHS（英国国家医疗服务体系）找了一份行政工作，我把它做得稍微临床化了一些，我可以做一些审计，并为审计进行临床访谈，然后我发表了审计报告，因为我想尝试一下。后来有人说：“来找个助理工作吧，但你需要有一些经验。”于是我冒了个险，辞去了有养老金和两份收入的全职工作，带着房贷和两个孩子，跳槽去了一份六个月的固定期限心理学助理工作，薪水更少。我想：“我必须这样做，必须这样做。”然后我开始在慢性疲劳服务部门工作，一位出色的心理学家领导着那个部门。
but it was only six months she said we can't do any more after that and then I got another job in forensics in the same trust but again only six months and it was there I really studied to apply for the doctorate you know when I did oh I missed a bit I did an honorary assistant psychology job in the evening after my admin job all day in a learning disability unit with challenging behavior and the year before my supervisor had asked me to do the doctorate form and I had been like okay I'll do it and then when I went to my next supervision with him he said where is it I said it went in the shredder and it was the most cathartic experience ever because I could see the gaps I didn't have which is what then made he said take the risk go fix them
但那只有六个月，她说之后就不能再续聘了。后来我在同一个信托机构的法医部门又找了一份工作，但同样只有六个月。正是在那里，我真正开始申请博士课程。哦，我漏了一点，我在做全职行政工作的同时，晚上还在一个有挑战性行为的学习障碍部门做无薪心理学助理。前一年，我的主管曾让我填写博士申请表，我当时想：“好吧，我来填。”但当我下次去接受督导时，他说：“表呢？”我说：“进碎纸机了。”那是我经历过最宣泄的时刻，因为我看到了自己所欠缺的差距，这正是他让我去冒险、去弥补的原因。
so I did that and then yeah I applied for the doctorate thinking go for feedback because nobody gets on the doctorate first time or it's quite rare the Trent course is quite grueling like really grueling um and I thought I'll go for the feedback but I made sure I studied every night in prep for that interview just so I could go for the feedback but I made sure I studied every night in prep for that interview just so I could give myself the best shot and that year they dropped the places from 20 to 19 and I was first reserved for a place and that's how I got that's from the RAF different things onto the onto the doctorate that's incredible deborah and actually a real few magic moments there you know the moment of um discovering accidentally you know
所以我做了，然后我申请了博士课程，心想：“去争取反馈吧，因为没人能第一次就考上博士，这很罕见。”Trent课程非常艰苦，真的非常艰苦。我想：“我去争取反馈吧，但我确保每天晚上都为面试做准备，这样我才能给自己最好的机会。”那一年，他们把名额从20个减少到了19个，我是第一候补。这就是我从空军一路走到博士课程的经历。这太不可思议了，Deborah，确实有几个神奇的时刻，比如意外发现心理学学位，然后被告知有阅读障碍，你知道，这可能让很多事情突然变得合理，
psychology degree really and then being told you're dyslexic and do you know it was like potentially lots of things suddenly might have added up and, you know, ends came together that really gave you important answers. And then, of course, I think telling you that you can't do something, I think it's probably similar to telling me that you can't do something. It's really difficult. It's like, well, I'll show you, you know. Yeah, I really try and being because, you know, also on on the doctorate course I'm the only person on the Trent course to actually submit to full thesis because and they failed my thesis on a technicality
一切都串联起来了，这真的给了你重要的答案。当然，我觉得告诉别人“你做不到”，这可能和我被告知“你做不到”时一样。这真的很困难。就像是，“好吧，我会证明给你看。”是的，我真的尝试过，因为在博士课程期间，我是Trent课程中唯一一个提交完整论文的人，因为他们以一个技术性问题为由挂了我的论文，
of one word which my tutor had actually changed my research question with me and they failed me on that question and they said I had to do a brand new thesis from scratch and they thought I'd resign they thought I'd come off the course because I wouldn't want I wouldn't have had time to do another thesis and I turned that thesis around in 13 months from idea to ethics well I didn't need the ethics still to put it through 13 months start to finish and it but I put you know I went up to like nearly 15 stone I was very heavy you know my husband was away in the RAF he did he did the Libya campaign he's done Afghanistan during that time you know he did Iraq prior to that so the four years I was on my doctorate course I think he probably only spent about 200 days of that four years at home
那是一个我导师和我一起修改过的研究问题，他们却因为那个问题挂了我。他们说我必须从头开始写一篇全新的论文。他们以为我会辞职，以为我会退出课程，因为我没有时间再写一篇论文了。但我从构思到伦理审查，在13个月内完成了那篇论文。我甚至不需要伦理审查来通过它，13个月从头到尾。我当时体重增加了近15英石（约95公斤），非常重。我丈夫当时在空军，他参加了利比亚战役，在那期间他还去了阿富汗，在此之前他还去了伊拉克。所以在我读博士的四年里，我想他大概只在家待了200天。
in that four years and I had a and I had a child to look after my eldest had moved out and it was just it was it was a difficult time but it's well worth it for what I do now that said it really shows what we're doing to our aspiring psychologists doesn't it you know because we are trying to live lives at the same time and it is a grueling process you know there is many different um plates that you're having to spin at that time you know you had the additional um I was gonna say complication but let's say let's say additional joy of being a mother um no seriously it felt like a complication at the time because nobody else on my course had children well there was only one other lady that had children and she she also found being a mother
在那四年里，我还要照顾孩子。我的大孩子已经搬出去了，那真是一段艰难的时光，但为了我现在所做的工作，这一切都是值得的。这确实显示了我们对那些有抱负的心理学家做了什么，不是吗？因为我们同时还在努力生活，这是一个艰苦的过程。在那段时间里，你有很多盘子要同时旋转。你还有额外的……我本来想说是“复杂情况”，但我们说是“额外的快乐”，那就是为人母。不，说真的，当时感觉就像是一种复杂情况，因为我课程里没有其他人有孩子。好吧，只有另一位女士有孩子，她也觉得为人母
quite challenging you know the rest not even all of them were married you know they didn't have that juggling act and I think we are you know sometimes when you see these assistants desperate to get on a course and celebrate and they've got on a course like I remember cheering when I got on the course and when I reflected back on it the other week I was like really I don't think I'd be cheering if I knew what I was in for it is and some courses I've got to say are really better than others and more diverse than others uh my course was not um it was really challenging but I'm they taught me a lot although trying to tell me that I would no longer be dyslexic after I finished the course
相当具有挑战性。其他人甚至不是都结了婚，他们没有那种需要平衡的生活。我认为，有时当你看到那些渴望进入课程并为此庆祝的助理们，他们考上了课程——我记得我考上时也在欢呼，但上周回顾时，我想：“真的吗？如果我知道接下来要面对什么，我想我不会欢呼的。”确实如此，而且我必须说，有些课程确实比其他课程更好、更多元化。我的课程不是，它真的很有挑战性，但他们教会了我很多。尽管他们试图告诉我，在我完成课程后，我就不再有阅读障碍了。
I you know they know something we don't about dyslexia apparently I was going to do that much reading and writing I would cure myself yeah interesting again they you know a lot of academic psychologists that teach clinical psychologists you know are very different you know and i think clinical psychologists then go off to split in different domains you know some go neuroscience some go academic you know i think i was very much i wanted to help people I wanted to help overcome trauma because you know for me being a child I did a lot of trauma I had a lot of trauma in the RAF and I just felt that I could I could really understand people not from a book not from a manual but from actually from some lived experience of just being in services.
他们似乎知道一些关于阅读障碍的我们不知道的事情。我当时想，如果我要读写那么多东西，我就会治愈自己。是的，这很有趣。很多教临床心理学家的学术心理学家非常不同。我认为临床心理学家后来会分流到不同的领域，有的去神经科学，有的去学术界。我想我非常明确，我想帮助人们，我想帮助克服创伤，因为对我来说，作为一个孩子，我经历了很多创伤，在空军时也有很多创伤。我只是觉得我能真正理解人们，不是从书本上，不是从手册里，而是从在部队服役的真实生活经验中。
There's lots of evidence to suggest, isn't there, that people who've had developmental trauma are more likely to end up in an armed force or in prison as well, you know? Yeah, yeah. Well, if you think about the ACEs, that's very much so. But the military does attract people with a lot of developmental trauma gives them a real family yeah you know it gives them a purpose and a structure and boundaries and rules you know like i'm early for everything
有很多证据表明，经历过发展性创伤的人更有可能进入武装部队或最终入狱，不是吗？是的，是的。如果你想想ACEs（不良童年经历），确实如此。但军队确实吸引了很多有发展性创伤的人，给了他们一个真正的家庭，给了他们目标、结构、界限和规则。比如，我做什么都早到，
like literally everything i can't be on time because that's late because the military teach you that if you're going to do something, you're five minutes early because that means you're on time. Oh, Deborah, even getting ready for this podcast, I confirmed with you, didn't I, as I was about to eat my lunch. And you were like, yep, I'm just making a cup of tea and then I'll be ready. And I was like, oh, my God, I'm still eating my yoghurt. But that's how it goes.
真的是每一件事。我不能准时，因为准时就是迟到。因为军队教你，如果你要做某事，你要提前五分钟，因为那才意味着你准时。哦，Deborah，即使是准备这次播客，我正要吃午饭时和你确认，你当时说：“好的，我正在泡杯茶，然后就准备好了。”我当时想：“天哪，我还在吃我的酸奶。”但事情就是这样。
That's just, you know, I've been out of the military a lot longer now than I was in it you know I left in 2006 but I you know I just I'm more I still have some of those ways I like if I tell somebody I'm going to do something I do it I never break a promise um I work way too hard because in the military there's a really hard work ethic. So I do know that. But sometimes that can also in clinical psychology worlds or that's not what they're used to. They're not used to somebody like me. And again, if you're a little bit different, regardless whether it's sexuality, whether it's color of skin, whether it's class and background, you know, if you're a a bit different you're going to really feel the weight of the clinical psychology course sometimes
这只是……我离开军队的时间比我在里面待的时间长多了，我2006年就离开了，但我仍然保留着那些习惯。如果我告诉别人我要做什么，我就一定会做到，我从不违背诺言。我工作太努力了，因为在军队里有一种非常刻苦的职业道德。所以我确实知道这一点。但有时在临床心理学界，他们不习惯这样。他们不习惯像我这样的人。同样，如果你有点不同，无论是因为性取向、肤色、阶级还是背景，如果你有点不同，你有时真的会感受到临床心理学课程的压力，
because it can feel like you don't fit in that you don't belong there um and I was very prickly on my doctor course I'm not going to lie I think I probably annoyed a few people at times because I constantly ask questions because I love verbal feedback. Like I really learn through people talking to me and listening. It's that connection as well, isn't it? Often in teaching, you don't have the same connection. It's not personal. Yeah.
因为它会让你觉得你不合群，你不属于那里。我在读博士时非常敏感，我不会撒谎。我想我可能有时确实惹恼了一些人，因为我不断地问问题，因为我喜欢口头反馈。我真的是通过人们与我交谈和倾听来学习的。这也是一种联系，不是吗？通常在教学中，你没有同样的联系。那不是个人的。
And I just needed it. But I think a lot of people wanted to be silent and thinkers or just get in and get finished early to go to the pub or just go and lay lay and do nothing I think there was probably some of them too yeah yeah that's not me I'm always like what I need to learn this more and I still like I do so much CPD now like I'm always on a CPD course like my husband's constantly saying what another course why do we need another course now. Like I'm always on a CPD course. My husband's constantly saying, what, another course? Why do we need another course? And I'm like, I need to know more because what if I don't know enough?
我只是需要它。但我认为很多人想保持沉默，做思考者，或者只是想早点结束去酒吧，或者只是去躺着什么都不做。我想可能也有这样的人。是的，那不是我。我总是想：“我需要学得更多。”我现在仍然做很多CPD（持续专业发展），我总是参加CPD课程。我丈夫总是说：“又一个课程？为什么我们现在还需要另一个课程？”我总是参加CPD课程。我丈夫总是说：“什么，又一个课程？为什么我们现在还需要另一个课程？”我说：“我需要知道更多，因为如果我知道的不够多怎么办？”
What if I don't know it? What if a client sits in front of me and I don't know what to do? It's like, you do need a mother. What's your advice to our audience if they are feeling that imposter syndrome, they've got that worry that that someone's going to ask them something that they don't know well do you know what when I was on my third year of my course my supervisor had said asked me a question that there was no answer to and I really really struggled to say the words I don't know they literally choked in my throat as I was scrambling in my head for the answer
如果我不知道怎么办？如果一个客户坐在我面前，我不知道该怎么办？这就像，你需要一个母亲。如果我们的听众感到冒名顶替综合症，担心有人会问他们不知道的问题，你有什么建议？你知道吗，当我读到课程第三年时，我的主管问了我一个没有答案的问题，我真的非常挣扎，说不出“我不知道”这几个字。当我脑子里在拼命寻找答案时，这几个字简直卡在我的喉咙里，
and I couldn't just say to her look I don't know I'll go check and I'll come back and see you I literally froze on the spot in that imposter syndrome moment I like she's found me out kind of thing and she's like Deborah I've asked you a question there is no answer to I was like why would you do that she said because you have to learn to say I don't know and I don't know can be okay and I was like what do you mean I don't know can be okay my chest in that moment felt like it was literally crushing I was like what do you mean I don't know is's okay we're meant to know the answer this is what they're paying us for and she's like no they're not they're paying for you to then go away and
我无法对她说：“看，我不知道，我去查一下，然后再回来找你。”在那一刻，我陷入了冒名顶替综合症，我僵住了。我觉得她看穿了我，而她说：“Deborah，我问了你一个问题，这个问题没有答案。”我说：“你为什么要那样做？”她说：“因为你必须学会说‘我不知道’，‘我不知道’是可以的。”我说：“你是什么意思，‘我不知道’是可以的？”那一刻，我的胸口感觉像是被压碎了。我说：“你是什么意思，‘我不知道’是可以的？我们应该知道答案，这就是他们付钱给我们的原因。”她说：“不，他们不是。他们付钱是为了让你去，
think about it come back to them I was like oh so that's now when I don't know something and somebody asked me something I genuinely don't know it it took me a long time to say I can just say I don't know. Okay, so you can sit with that now and be okay with that. But if people can get there quicker with that, it'll save them a whole host of worry and hassle. Yeah. So where did you end up working when you first qualified then?
思考一下，然后再回来告诉他们。”我说：“哦，原来是这样。”所以现在当我不了解某事，有人问我一些我确实不知道的问题时，我花了好长时间才学会说：“我可以只说我不知道。”好的，所以你现在可以接受这一点，并对此感到坦然。但如果人们能更快地做到这一点，那将为他们省去大量的担忧和麻烦。是的。那么你毕业后最终在哪里工作了呢？
What did you do? I got a job at Lincoln Prison. And I absolutely loved it. I was finishing my thesis. I didn't quite have my doctor's title or the banding or the pay, but that's OK. I absolutely loved it. I went in there and the guys at Lincoln Prison were amazing. I set up a trauma-informed work group for both prisoners in the vulnerable prison wing and then the other wings because you had to keep them very separate. And initially the prison thought we'd only do a group for one type of population, not for both.
你做了什么？我在林肯监狱找到了一份工作。我非常喜欢它。我当时正在完成我的论文。我还没有博士头衔，也没有相应的职级或薪水，但这没关系。我非常喜欢它。我进去后，林肯监狱的人们太棒了。我为弱势监狱区的囚犯和其他区域的囚犯建立了一个创伤知情工作小组，因为你必须把他们分开。起初，监狱认为我们只会为一种人群做小组，而不是两者都做。
And I just felt that both populations really needed it because the one thing we found, like you said earlier, the majority of people that end up in prison have had developmental trauma but the one biggest thing I found through working there was nobody recognized those guys as victims it was heartbreaking some of their stories Marianne were really really heartbreaking in terms of the abuse they suffered, the neglect they suffered, and the fact that nobody cared until they pitched up in the criminal justice system. And then there was more a big stick approach than a trauma-led approach. approach and it was through group work and eventually EMDR that the guys I worked with really started to notice their own victim status and how they needed that to heal but in doing that they noticed that they created victims and you know and the prisons put on these victim empathy courses that supposedly teach them how to have victim empathy but unless they truly get to the roots of their own trauma they have to defend the fact that they've got victims because it'll just make them feel more vulnerable okay so a lot of the
我只是觉得这两个群体确实都需要它，因为我们发现的一件事，就像你刚才说的，大多数最终入狱的人都有发展性创伤。但我通过在那里工作发现的最重要的一点是，没有人承认这些人是受害者。这令人心碎。Marianne，他们的一些故事真的非常令人心碎，关于他们遭受的虐待、忽视，以及在他们进入刑事司法系统之前，没有人关心他们。然后，比起创伤导向的方法，更多的是一种“大棒”政策。通过小组工作，最终通过EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工），我合作的人们真的开始注意到他们自己的受害者身份，以及他们如何需要这一点来治愈。但在这样做时，他们注意到他们也制造了受害者。你知道，监狱举办这些受害者同理心课程，据说教他们如何拥有受害者同理心，但除非他们真正触及自己创伤的根源，否则他们必须捍卫自己制造了受害者这一事实，因为这只会让他们感到更脆弱。好的，所以很多
joined up that compassion haven't you that's what you've done yeah but then i then then they started to spread my job a bit thin so I had to then cover Lincoln and Nottingham and then Lincoln Nottingham North Sea Camp the open prison and then it was Lincoln Nottingham North Sea Camp and Morton Hall the Immigration Removal Centre now that again was quite harrowing seeing people dragged in because they had failed to complete a form in time or were deemed to be a risk now yes if you commit a crime over a certain length of time apparently you then are likely to be deported however there was a lot of people in that immigration center who had not committed a crime who had come here for what they thought was a better life their journeys were terribly
把那种同情心结合起来了，不是吗？这就是你所做的。是的，但后来他们开始把我的工作范围分得太散，所以我不得不覆盖林肯、诺丁汉，然后是林肯、诺丁汉、北海营地（开放式监狱），然后是林肯、诺丁汉、北海营地和莫顿霍尔移民遣返中心。现在，再次看到人们因为没有及时填好表格或被认为有风险而被拖进来，这真是令人痛苦。现在，是的，如果你在一定时间内犯罪，显然你很可能会被驱逐出境。然而，那个移民中心里有很多人并没有犯罪，他们来到这里是为了他们认为更好的生活。他们的旅程非常
terribly distressing from leaving their country of origin and their family at home and being almost imprisoned because they tried to find work and do the right thing um and even some of the issues like the idea of sending somebody back to a country that was homosexual which which would have led to their death. You know, I just thought, no, that's not the society. So I felt like I had a real fight for them. So, you know, I wanted to get their voice heard within that system, within that home office system. So, again, in that place, I did teachings for home office staff around trauma and the impact of trauma because
非常令人痛苦，从离开原籍国和家里的家人，到因为试图寻找工作和做正确的事而几乎被监禁。甚至还有一些问题，比如把某人送回一个同性恋会被判死刑的国家。你知道，我只是想，不，那不是我们想要的社会。所以我感觉我必须为他们而战。所以，在那个地方，我为内政部工作人员做了关于创伤和创伤影响的教学，因为
they'd say well they didn't tell me that on the first I didn't hear that they haven't told me that so therefore they're lying to you and I'm like why do you think they might not have been able to tell you about their most traumatic experience anyhow and so we do some work on what was your interview skill like what how did you present them did you make them feel safe in the room and they're like it's not my job to make them feel safe um some of the immigration removal officers were brilliant and they'd get all that information it's the same as prison officers prison officers would say prisoners were needy and manipulative and they and they all they always choose the soft officers and And I said, and I remember saying to an officer one day, he said, am I being manipulated?
他们会说：“好吧，他们第一次没告诉我，我没听到，他们没告诉我，所以他们在对你撒谎。”我说：“你为什么认为他们可能无法告诉你他们最痛苦的经历呢？”所以我们做了一些工作，关于你的面试技巧是什么样的？你是如何呈现他们的？你让他们在房间里感到安全了吗？他们说：“让他们感到安全不是我的工作。”一些移民遣返官员非常出色，他们会得到所有这些信息。这和监狱官员一样，监狱官员会说囚犯是需要帮助的和操纵性的，他们总是选择软弱的官员。我记得有一天我对一位官员说，他说：“我被操纵了吗？”
And I said, who would you go to on this wing right now if you had a problem? Which officer would you select? And he named them and I said, why is your behavior then not deemed to be manipulative, but their behavior is when they choose the same officers? And so I did a lot of psychoeducation around that. I thought that was really important.
我说：“如果你现在在这个区遇到问题，你会去找谁？你会选择哪位官员？”他说了他们的名字，我说：“为什么你的行为不被认为是操纵性的，而当他们选择同样的官员时，他们的行为就是呢？”所以我围绕这一点做了很多心理教育。我认为这非常重要。
And it was a shame because the prison employed somebody to come in and be the boss of therapy services who had no therapy experience, wasn't a clinical psychologist, didn't meet this essential criteria. And then called me IAPT and told me I was to stop working with patients therapeutically, do desktop analysis. And at that point I said, no. If I'm not going to see and help patients, I'm leaving. And that's why I then went private. OK. Oh, it's very difficult, isn't it? Because I know, you know, this work matters deeply to us as clinicians and humans. And when we feel we can get that human connection and make a difference, even for one person, it's incredible and it's powerful.
很遗憾，因为监狱雇佣了一个没有任何治疗经验、不是临床心理学家、不符合基本标准的人来担任治疗服务的老板。然后他称我为IAPT（心理治疗改善获取计划），并告诉我停止对患者进行治疗性工作，去做桌面分析。在那一刻，我说：“不。如果我不去见患者并帮助他们，我就离开。”这就是我后来转向私营领域的原因。好的。哦，这非常困难，不是吗？因为我知道，这种工作对我们作为临床医生和人类来说意义重大。当我们觉得我们可以建立那种人际联系并产生影响时，即使是对一个人，那也是不可思议的，而且很有力量。
And it keeps you coming back to work, even on tricky days. But once someone gets in the way of, you know, I think it's that idea of moral injury, isn't it? And I'm not willing to work in that way. And that's actually more challenging to me to watch that go by and not be able to do anything. That becomes a trauma in itself for ourselves if we stay. And you're then left with the decision of leaving a job that you love and a client population that you love very much because I can't be party to it anymore I can't just go in and help people you know the amount of times I would go on a wing walk through and just stand with somebody and ground them you know I went to Nottingham once and I changed days just because I had to and as I walked in I heard that
它让你即使在棘手的日子里也愿意回来工作。但一旦有人阻碍了……我认为这就是道德伤害的概念，不是吗？我不愿意以那种方式工作。看着这一切发生却无能为力，对我来说更具挑战性。如果我们留下来，这本身就成了我们自己的创伤。你最终面临着离开一份你热爱的工作和一个你非常热爱的客户群的决定，因为我不能再参与其中了。我不能只是进去帮助人们。你知道，我多少次在走廊里走动，只是和某人站在一起，让他们落地（grounding）。你知道，我有一次去诺丁汉，我换了日子，因为我不得不这样做。当我走进去时，我听到
one of my patients was on the netting and they were calling in the national team to get him off and I and I wandered up to the wing. Can you tell us what can you tell us what that means? Paint us a picture of on what on the netting means. In each prison as you go up the steps there's a net between each floor so somebody can't fall and land on the bottom floor so they can't basically commit suicide but they're on this netting and it's quite still a little bit dangerous and they're literally suspended in the air on this net so if you fall from a trapeze rope onto some netting you'd normally be able to roll off and get off in the prison you can't really do that you have to then get yourself to the edge and you have to climb off um but prison officers because it's dangerous won't go on and get you off so they won't go get locked up they won't go back to
我的一位病人正在网架上，他们正在叫国家队把他弄下来。我走到走廊上。你能告诉我们那意味着什么吗？给我们描绘一下“在网架上”是什么意思。在每个监狱里，当你走上楼梯时，每层楼之间都有一个网，这样某人就不会掉下来摔在底层，所以他们基本上不能自杀。但他们在这个网上，这仍然有点危险，他们实际上悬在空中。所以如果你从秋千绳上掉到网上，你通常能滚下来离开。在监狱里，你不能那样做，你必须把自己弄到边缘，然后爬下来。但监狱官员因为这很危险，不会去把你弄下来。他们不会去被锁起来，他们不会回到
their room they won't do what they're being told to do so the prison officers have been doing this merry dance for a few hours now he's been on the netting he's not coming off he's right in the center and i so i go in and he sees my face as if saying no it's not necessarily an act of suicidality it's an act of I really don't want to be around anyone I don't want to do what you want me to do I don't want to do but also he knew he would get a kick in because the national team would come in and manhandle him off there and put him down to segregation so he'd get to be alone in a room in segregation away from all of it so it was functional in the fact that it's like basic behavior in nurseries isn't it you know it makes a lot of sense he just
他们的房间，他们不会做被告知要做的事。所以监狱官员已经跳了几个小时的“旋转舞”了。他在网架上，他不下来，他在正中央。所以我进去了，他看到我的脸，好像在说：“不，这不一定是一种自杀行为，这是一种‘我真的不想和任何人在一起，我不想做你们想让我做的事，我不想做’的行为。”但也因为他知道他会挨打，因为国家队会进来强行把他弄下来，把他送到隔离区。所以他可以独自待在隔离区的房间里，远离这一切。所以这在功能上是有效的，就像托儿所里的基本行为一样，不是吗？这很有道理。他只是
needed to de-stimulate it was too busy for him it was too much he was overwhelmed he was also due to be released he'd been in prison on and off since he was like 17 he's never really known the outside world he was bloody petrified just dysregulated in every area yeah so I go on and I say to the prison officers look I'm gonna get him off here and they laughed and like he never comes off he gets this is the process and I said no I'm gonna get him off but when I get him off we're going into the little office and I'm gonna just talk to him and that's not protocol he has to get no I'm like no but neither is me getting him off protocol let's just try to do something different let's see if we can avoid him getting the kicking avoiding going to segregation let's see if I can get him that like let's see if we can
需要去刺激（de-stimulate）。对他来说太忙了，太多了，他不知所措。他也要被释放了，他从17岁起就断断续续地在监狱里，他从来没有真正了解过外面的世界。他吓坏了，在各个方面都失调了。是的，所以我走过去对监狱官员说：“看，我会把他弄下来的。”他们笑了，说：“他从来不下来，这是流程。”我说：“不，我会把他弄下来的。但当我把他弄下来时，我们要去小办公室，我只是要和他谈谈。”那不是规程，他必须……我说：“不，我把他弄下来也不是规程。让我们尝试做点不同的事情。让我们看看能否避免他挨打，避免去隔离区。让我们看看能否让他……”
re-regulate him let's see if we can get him to choose a different behavior that's more adaptive let's go with that idea so literally i walked over and i stood there and he's like that's that's what you're doing here that's what you're doing here and i was like i've come to get you off the net and he's like but they'll give me a kick in devs if i come off those prison officers or jump on straight away i said no i've got the assurance that's not going to happen me and you are going to go to the office and we're going to have an hour just in the office and he's like you promise if I come off this net and we're having that hour and I was like promise and literally I had to get him even before he could get himself over the bars I got him just to notice the feel of the netting on his hands to notice the feel
让他重新调节。让我们看看能否让他选择一种更具适应性的不同行为。让我们试试那个想法。所以，我真的走过去站在那里，他说：“这就是你在这里做的？这就是你在这里做的？”我说：“我来把你从网上弄下来。”他说：“但如果我下来，他们会打我的，Deb。那些监狱官员会直接跳上来。”我说：“不，我有保证，那不会发生。我和你要去办公室，我们要在那儿待一个小时。”他说：“你保证如果我从网上下来，我们就待那一个小时？”我说：“保证。”我甚至在他自己能越过栏杆之前，就让他注意到网上他手的感觉，注意到
of himself there to notice the connection with me and then to come and hold on to the bars and notice how cold they felt on his hands and just ground himself before he then flipped himself back over the bars onto the landing to then walk down the landing to go in a little office and he sat in that little office on the floor like he was a five-year-old boy petrified saying that they're gonna burst through the doors don't don't want you to get hurt Deb so you stay away from me just in case they burst through the doors Debs they're gonna don't don't want you to get hurt Debs so you stay away from me just in case they burst through the doors and I can't have you hurt and I'm like they're not coming in it's fine let's and I got him regulated and I said but what's this all about and he said um my girlfriend wrote a letter in and she's breaking up with me and I'm due out next week I didn't know what else to do so I thought well they'll keep if I create havoc I get I'll get extra days and then I might stay in and I'm like are you really that scared so we then
他在那里的感觉，注意到与我的联系，然后让他过来抓住栏杆，注意到它们在他手上感觉有多冷，让他自己落地，然后再翻过栏杆回到平台上，走下平台去那个小办公室。他坐在那个小办公室的地板上，就像一个五岁的男孩，吓坏了，说：“他们会冲进门来的，别，别，我不想让你受伤，Deb，所以你离我远点，以防他们冲进门来，Debs，他们会……别，别，我不想让你受伤，Debs，所以你离我远点，以防他们冲进门来，我不能让你受伤。”我说：“他们不会进来的，没关系，让我们……”我让他调节好了，我说：“这到底是怎么回事？”他说：“我女朋友写了一封信，她要和我分手，我下周就要出狱了。我不知道还能做什么，所以我心想，好吧，如果我制造混乱，我会得到额外的刑期，然后我可能会留下来。”我说：“你真的那么害怕吗？”所以我们后来
were able to process why he was really that scared of being released and what stepping stones did we need to put in place for him to be released safely so it was a really it was a beautiful thing but and I do miss not being able to go do that because those clients aren't going to walk through the door of my private practice which is a shame I bet you still live in their hearts and that's the incredible power about what they wrote to me some of them wrote to me um you know I've had drawings I've had writings I once worked with a guy who called me a see you next Tuesday for eight sessions, ripped up loads of ID cards, wouldn't work. And then I said to him one day, look, I need to be your co-driver on this journey of change.
能够处理他为什么真的那么害怕被释放，以及我们需要为他安全释放设置什么垫脚石。所以这是一件非常美好的事情。但我确实怀念不能再那样做了，因为那些客户不会走进我的私人诊所，这很遗憾。我敢打赌你仍然活在他们的心中，这就是他们写给我的信的不可思议的力量。你知道，我收到过画，收到过文字。我曾经和一个家伙一起工作，他连续八次会谈都叫我“下周二见”（骂人的谐音），撕碎了很多身份证，不配合工作。然后有一天我对他说：“看，我需要成为你改变之旅的副驾驶。”
Like, let's get on this train. Let's make a difference. I'll be a co-driver. And let's see what we can do. He's a Manchester lad. He was over here in Lincoln. You know, we talked about Holland's pies and Morby's bread you know it was something that just helped us connect and if you're from Manchester and Lancashire you'll know what Holland's pies are if you're from anywhere in the country you might have to google them and it was something so simple to him and he'd he'd been failed by mental health services and every prison he'd ever been in he was hooked on lots of prescription medication you know he was on the hook but he had been in and out of prison again since 15 putting this window through this house um constantly and then we did
“就像，让我们上这列火车。让我们做出改变。我会成为副驾驶。让我们看看我们能做什么。”他是曼彻斯特的小伙子。他在林肯这边。你知道，我们谈论了Holland's派和Morby's面包，你知道，这只是帮助我们建立联系的东西。如果你来自曼彻斯特和兰开夏郡，你会知道Holland's派是什么；如果你来自全国其他地方，你可能得去谷歌一下。对他来说，这很简单。他被心理健康服务机构辜负了，在他待过的每一所监狱里，他都沉迷于大量的处方药。你知道，他上瘾了，但他从15岁起就一直进出监狱，砸碎这所房子的窗户……不断地。然后我们做了
some really good work with him and he recognized the house that he keeps putting the windows through is the man that abused him but what he'd failed to realize in his head was that man had moved on years ago and it was always new families in that house that he was putting their windows through on. So nobody joined up the dots that this was part of his trauma. And nobody treated his trauma. You know, this dad had been abused by everybody in his family. It was probably one of the most horrible abuse cases I've ever heard. And we worked really well together and then I managed to get him in a drug rehab service over in Manchester he then wrote to me and said
一些非常好的工作，他意识到他一直砸碎窗户的那所房子是那个虐待他的人的家。但他没意识到的是，那个人多年前就搬走了，他一直砸的是那所房子里新住户的窗户。所以没有人把这些点连起来，意识到这是他创伤的一部分。没有人治疗他的创伤。你知道，这个孩子被他家里的每个人虐待过。这可能是我听过的最可怕的虐待案件之一。我们合作得很好，后来我设法让他进入了曼彻斯特的一个戒毒服务机构。他后来写信给我说
do you want to come to my graduation because I'm about to drive my train for myself I no longer need a co-driver but you're still there and it was like oh it brings that shivers down my spine it's just how amazing is that really really incredible it was never was never gonna never been it's never been seen before so to me that was beautiful but I still do some I do some free work in clinic with some veterans that can't afford private therapy who've been let down by the system so because i am a veteran that they're like the group i tend to even in the prison i used to go to the veteran groups you know the prison officers would go to those veteran groups we made the prison officers would just put a normal jumper on over their uniform kind of thing so they didn't look like prison officers while we all sat around the table um and uh we'd take biscuits in and we'd have a cup of tea now i know tea and biscuit is something
你想来参加我的毕业典礼吗？因为我马上就要自己开火车了，不再需要副驾驶了。但你还在那里，那种感觉就像……哦，这让我脊背发凉，这真是太棒了，真的非常不可思议。这以前从未有过，也从未被见过，所以对我来说这很美。但我仍然在诊所做一些志愿工作，帮助那些负担不起私人治疗、被系统辜负的退伍军人。因为我也是一名退伍军人，他们是我倾向于帮助的群体。即使在监狱里，我过去也常去参加退伍军人小组。你知道，狱警也会参加那些小组，我们让狱警在制服外面套上一件普通的套头衫，这样他们看起来就不像狱警了。我们大家围坐在桌子旁，带上饼干，喝杯茶。现在我知道茶和饼干是某种
that you think but they don't get them in prison you know and it was just that area to like let's think about this let's just did you take did you take nice biscuits yeah of course i did when it was my turn but then they couldn't have foil on and you couldn't have this and you had to decant them out if they had any foil to them that's a risk hazard in prison so you weren't allowed um yeah but prison work was amazing so anybody that wants to go to prison by the way absolutely 100 and if you look at the Scotland stuff they're doing loads on compassionate prisons amazing I loved forensic work until I became a mummy and then for me it just changed the way I felt I felt more vulnerable um but I know lots
你可能会想到的东西，但他们在监狱里可吃不到。这只是为了创造一个空间，让我们思考一下。你带了好的饼干吗？是的，轮到我的时候我当然带了。但他们不能有锡纸包装，你不能带这个，如果包装上有锡纸，你必须把它们倒出来，因为在监狱里那是安全隐患，所以不允许。是的，但监狱工作太棒了，所以任何想去监狱工作的人，绝对百分之百推荐。如果你看看苏格兰那边，他们正在做很多关于富有同情心的监狱的工作，太棒了。我曾经很喜欢法医工作，直到我当了妈妈，那之后我的感觉就变了，我感到更脆弱了。但我认识很多人
of people that do work um in prisons um whilst being a parent as well yeah that was hard because there was only one time it really impacted on me which was when I was doing the assessment of a sex offender and and he'd come in on multiple multiple counts scout leader that impacted me on what I was going to let my son do at the clubs he was going to I was constantly hyper vigilant around that and I started to notice that was not a great thing as a mummy um but this day when I was interviewing this sex offender he literally told me about he told me about boyfriend and I'd carried on with the assessment and then all of a sudden I went uh hang on a minute just just let me tell you back in a minute how old is your boyfriend and he said the same age as my son at the time and I was like
在监狱工作的同时也是父母。是的，那很艰难，因为只有一次它真正影响到了我，当时我正在评估一名性犯罪者。他因为多项罪名入狱，还是个童子军领袖。这影响了我对自己儿子参加俱乐部活动的看法，我对此一直保持高度警惕，我开始意识到作为妈妈这并不是一件好事。但那天我在采访这个性犯罪者时，他真的跟我说了他的男朋友，我继续进行评估，突然我停下来说：“等等，让我确认一下，你男朋友多大了？”他说和我儿子当时一样大，我当时就觉得
that's and I and I was quite shocked and I said to him that's not your boyfriend that's a victim and I was really indignant about it and then anyway I then took a breath and I carried on with the assessment and at the end of the assessment I said to him how did that go for you and he was like well you really didn't like it when I talked about my boyfriend and I said he's not your boyfriend and he's like yeah but you didn't like it he wanted me to agree with him and I can't you can't collude you're just gone but that was the first time I ever felt quite rude in a session where normally as clinical psychologists that we keep that nice face sometimes so yes and we'll just you know but I'm really I've got facial leakage like
这……我当时非常震惊，我对他说：“那不是你的男朋友，那是受害者。”我对此感到非常愤慨。然后我深吸了一口气，继续进行评估。评估结束时，我问他：“你觉得这次谈话怎么样？”他说：“你谈到我男朋友时真的很不喜欢。”我说：“他不是你男朋友。”他说：“是啊，但你不喜欢。”他想让我同意他的观点，但我不能，你不能同流合污，你必须保持专业。但那是我第一次在咨询中感到如此失礼，通常作为临床心理学家，我们有时会保持那种友好的面孔，所以是的，我们会……但我真的，我的面部表情会泄露情绪，就像
you what you see with me is what yeah I'm like if I if I'm know but I'm really I've got facial leakage like you what you see with me is what yeah I'm like if I if I'm confused or I'm horrified I show it because I think it's more transparent and genuine for the client but with him that day I was furious but it really impacted on me on my own child that day was really hard and the way we deal with that is obviously take it to supervision as well don't we let's model that as appropriate as well yeah we take it to supervision but sometimes supervision sometimes you need to go for a run yeah or you need to scream it out or you need to go then actually there's a whole host of good ways the supervision for me any assistant psychologist anyone that wanting to get on this course
你看到的我就是真实的我。是的，如果我感到困惑或震惊，我会表现出来，因为我认为这对客户来说更透明、更真诚。但那天对他，我非常愤怒，这确实影响到了我对自己孩子的看法，那天真的很难受。我们处理这种情况的方法显然是带到督导中去讨论，不是吗？让我们把这作为适当的示范。是的，我们带到督导中，但有时督导……有时你需要去跑步，或者你需要大喊大叫，或者你需要去……实际上有很多好的方法。对我来说，督导对于任何想要参加这门课程的助理心理学家来说
get in the habit of being vulnerable in your supervision because yes when you go it's all right to swear on these things we can we can bleep it but basically when you fuck up you don't learn if you don't go talk about it yeah how do you learn to overcome something you've done wrong if you don't talk about it open and honestly and supervision because then you learn better and we get better at who we are we do we do um i know that my audience will be really keen just for us to clarify the process around what happens if when you're on a doctorate course your thesis is failed so my understanding is that you then qualify as an unqualified um clinical psychologist and you don't get paid anymore you have to do the
养成在督导中展现脆弱的习惯，因为是的，当你去的时候……在这些事情上说脏话是可以的，我们可以消音，但基本上，如果你搞砸了却不去谈论它，你就学不到东西。是的，如果你不去谈论它，不去在督导中公开诚实地交流，你怎么能学会克服你做错的事情呢？因为这样你才能学得更好，我们才能在自我成长上变得更好。我们确实会这样做。我知道我的听众会非常渴望我们澄清一下，如果你在博士课程期间论文不及格会发生什么。据我所知，你会被认定为不合格的临床心理学家，不再获得报酬，你必须在
thesis in your own time and you'll need a job is that right no so basically you're still attributed to the course that you're doing your thesis for you're right you have to stay on your band sick uh trainee wage wherever you are on that you might the increment wherever you are that's where you stay so you go still as in in your employment contract it will say that your employment will be terminated if you do not complete your doctorate course so yeah so you're doing the qualified role but you're doing it as a band six well not a band seven and you don't get the study day yeah you don't get any study leave you don't get any study time in your new role so basically what I'm saying to everybody is get your thesis done before you
自己的时间里完成论文，而且你需要一份工作，是这样吗？不，基本上你仍然隶属于你正在撰写论文的课程。你是对的，你必须留在你的六级实习生工资水平上，无论你在哪里，你都保持那个增量。所以你的雇佣合同里会写明，如果你没有完成博士课程，你的雇佣关系将被终止。所以是的，你在做合格的角色，但你是以六级而不是七级的身份在做，而且你没有学习日。是的，你在新职位中没有学习假，也没有学习时间。所以基本上我想对大家说的是，在你们
qualify but what you're also saying is it's not it's doable it's not the end of the world and this does this does happen um and it might not be reasons that feel like they're within your control um but you can survive it and actually in the grand scheme of things that one year hasn't really made an impact on your career and it's likely that you would have but you would have doing the same job anyway you just got less money for it yeah yeah but the thing is is it did take a real toll on my mental health because they kept saying things like this is a declensi normal version there's no dyslexic version this is a declensi you know people like you people should my course director at the time my course director said that to me another another member of the research team said to me people like you lower
获得资格之前完成论文。但你同时也说，这是可行的，并不是世界末日，这种情况确实会发生。而且原因可能感觉不在你的控制范围内，但你可以挺过去。实际上，从长远来看，那一年并没有真正对你的职业生涯产生影响，而且很可能你无论如何都会做同样的工作，只是钱少了一点。是的，是的，但问题是它确实对我的心理健康造成了很大的打击，因为他们一直说类似“这是阅读障碍者的正常版本，没有阅读障碍版本，这是阅读障碍者……”你知道，像你这样的人，我当时的课程主任说，研究团队的另一名成员对我说：“像你这样的人降低了
the academic superiority of our course you know when you're getting those comments said to you at the same time and you can't on behalf of on behalf of clinical psychology dr deb. Deborah Kingston, I'd like to apologize to you because that's not OK. You know, that's not all right. But that's the thing. People hear these comments, they hear things. And what they do is they'll internalize them based on their own history. Sometimes there's no need, Dr. Marianne Trent, for you to apologize for clinical psychologists because you're not narrow minded, small, bigoted and discriminatory. So, you know, don't apologise for people who choose to have that behaviour. Yeah, I know. But I'm just I'm sorry for humans what they've done.
我们课程的学术优越性。”你知道，当你同时听到这些评论时，你无法……我代表临床心理学，黛博拉·金斯顿博士，我想向你道歉，因为那是不对的。你知道，那是不对的。但这就是问题所在。人们听到这些评论，他们听到这些话，然后他们会根据自己的历史将它们内化。有时，玛丽安·特伦特博士，你不需要为临床心理学家道歉，因为你不是那种心胸狭窄、偏执和歧视的人。所以，你知道，不要为那些选择那种行为的人道歉。是的，我知道。但我只是为人类所做的事情感到抱歉。
But I'm aware of the time I could talk to you for weeks um but something I ask um everybody is for any advice they've got for reducing burnout um along the journey for aspiring psychologists what top tips would you give I would definitely say embrace yourself with people around you that love you because it's number one factor I would get some support on your journey so like I think you do a lot of literature and a lot of things I think I don't think we've had as much out for aspiring psychologists as we've currently got now and I think it's tapping into those resources because I genuinely at times felt quite alone and if you can connect with like-minded people in some form of collective experience I think it's invaluable because I think
但我意识到时间有限，我可以和你聊上几周。但我问每个人的一个问题是，对于减少职业倦怠有什么建议？对于有抱负的心理学家，你有什么顶级建议？我绝对会说，拥抱你身边爱你的人，因为这是第一要素。我会在你的旅程中寻求一些支持。比如，我认为你阅读了很多文献，做了很多事情。我认为我们现在为有抱负的心理学家提供的支持比以往任何时候都多，我认为关键在于利用这些资源。因为我确实有时感到非常孤独，如果你能以某种集体经验的形式与志同道合的人建立联系，我认为这是无价的，因为我认为
it'll keep you right your hobbies I think it's so important to keep an essence of you even though at times you might not feel like you've got any time for them you can imagine doing them just for a couple of minutes and it will really help because that sense of imagination your body knows where that like knitting or crocheting or art or dance or drama your body knows where that feels good for it it's got a good memory of that so even for five minutes and then the most chaotic of days when we're trying to juggle 15 plates stop for a moment imagine you're doing the thing that you love the most and just really sense it in your body and then you'll feel like you've just got a pep of energy to then keep going which should in theory stop some burnout oh you're worth your
它会让你保持正轨。你的爱好，我认为保持自我的本质非常重要，即使有时你觉得没有时间去做。你可以想象只花几分钟去做它们，这真的会有帮助。因为那种想象力，你的身体知道像编织、钩针、艺术、舞蹈或戏剧这些活动在哪里感觉良好，它有很好的记忆。所以即使只有五分钟，在最混乱的日子里，当我们试图同时处理15件事时，停下来片刻，想象你在做你最喜欢的事情，并在你的身体里真正感受它，然后你会觉得你又有了能量继续前进，这在理论上应该能阻止一些职业倦怠。哦，你真是
weight in gold deborah um amazing advice and you know i hope that our audience are just eating us up with a spoon it's lovely um where can people connect with you or learn more about you um if they should want to well I'm on LinkedIn I'm not we listen I put the odd post out here and there but I do I always respond to private messages you know I've never let anybody down with that because I think it's important to pay back you know but I'm not the best at giving advice like on forms I'm dyslexic people it's not my strength um however what I would say is really analyze that you know the application form for the doctorate of the clearinghouse really look at the scope of everything that you really need to do and then ask yourself do I have that experience and if I don't have that experience where can I
价值连城，黛博拉，非常棒的建议。你知道，我希望我们的听众正在如饥似渴地吸收这些内容，这太好了。如果人们想联系你或了解更多关于你的信息，他们应该去哪里？我在领英上，我不……听着，我偶尔会发帖，但我总是回复私信。你知道，我从未让任何人失望，因为我认为回馈很重要。但我不太擅长在表格上提供建议，我有阅读障碍，这不是我的强项。然而，我想说的是，真正分析一下博士课程的申请表格，真正看看你需要做的所有事情的范围，然后问自己：我有这些经验吗？如果我没有这些经验，我可以在哪里
go get it because I think it's important so many people apply for a doctorate course before they're actually ready to apply so the year I shredded my application form it actually felt like a cathartic experience because it would have just felt like for me like a huge failure but I could see from the form there was gaps so I think it's just being objective as well through this whole process and if you have applied for the doctor course I knew a girl that applied for it four times on the bounce got on the reserve list and on the fifth time of asking didn't even get an interview but then on the sixth time got on the course it's interesting because actually I think this amount of time to get on means that when you get on I think you're ready for training but there are some courses I know
去获得它？因为我认为这很重要。很多人在还没准备好申请之前就申请了博士课程。所以那一年我撕毁了我的申请表，这实际上感觉是一种宣泄，因为对我来说，那感觉就像一次巨大的失败。但我能从表格中看出有差距。所以我认为在整个过程中保持客观也很重要。如果你申请了博士课程……我认识一个女孩，连续申请了四次，进了候补名单，第五次申请时甚至没得到面试机会，但第六次就进了课程。这很有趣，因为实际上我认为花这么多时间才进去意味着当你进去时，你已经为培训做好了准备。但我知道有些课程
we're running over time but there are some courses who now don't even look at the form so long as you meet essential criteria you can then do an assessment test and if you come first on the assessment test for example not first but the first however many you then get invited to interview so the form's not even really being used so in theory you could potentially get on very soon after your undergrad but I needed all those extra years even the time I spent sitting in a hammock in Thailand for a few months you know I needed that time to help me later in my career and I was the same I did my honorary where I really learned about behaviorism I learned about wards I learned about nursing teams the dynamics of teams then I went to the chronic
我们超时了，但有些课程现在甚至不看表格，只要你符合基本标准，你就可以参加评估测试。如果你在评估测试中名列前茅，比如不是第一，而是前多少名，你就会被邀请参加面试。所以表格甚至没有真正被使用。所以理论上，你可能在本科毕业后很快就能进去。但我需要所有那些额外的年份，甚至是我在泰国吊床上坐了几个月的时间。你知道，我需要那些时间来帮助我以后的职业生涯。我也是一样，我做了我的荣誉职位，在那里我真正了解了行为主义，我了解了病房，我了解了护理团队，团队的动态。然后我去了慢性
fatigue service and I learned about occupational therapists and support workers and the vital role they play and the team element and group work and then I went to forensics and I really cut my teeth and I had an amazing supervisor I'm going to give her a shout out because without her, I wouldn't be here, which is Dr. Kerry Beckley. She was phenomenal. And she was the one that mentored me. I'm getting on to the course and then beyond that three years of my doctorate. So, you know, it's about without that levels of experience, joining it up together, I would never have got on. And I wouldn't be the clinical psychologist I am today doing my trauma informed stuff because I've gone more specialism to be trauma informed. I can't I don't treat everybody. I don't have a list as long as you are.
疲劳服务中心，我了解了职业治疗师和支持工作者，以及他们在团队中发挥的重要作用，还有团队元素和小组工作。然后我去了法医部门，我真正磨练了自己，我有一位很棒的督导。我要特别感谢她，因为没有她，我就不会有今天，她就是凯里·贝克利博士。她非常出色。是她指导我进入了课程，然后是之后三年的博士生涯。所以，你知道，如果没有这些经验的积累，把它们结合在一起，我永远不会成功。我也不会成为今天的临床心理学家，做我的创伤知情工作，因为我为了成为创伤知情专家而进行了更多的专业化。我不能……我不治疗所有人。我的名单没有你那么长。
I do all these conditions. I'm a specialist in all this because I'm not. I'm just trauma. And that's me. Very lucky they would be to see you. Deborah, it's been such a pleasure having you here. I might well invite you back in future because there's lots and lots I could talk to you about. But thank you so much for your time. It's been a joy. You're welcome.
我做所有这些病症。我是所有这些方面的专家，因为我不是。我只是创伤方面的。这就是我。能见到你他们会很幸运。黛博拉，很高兴你能来。我以后很可能会再邀请你，因为还有很多很多我可以和你聊的话题。但非常感谢你的时间。这真是一种乐趣。不客气。
Oh, thank you for listening or watching. If you're on YouTube, I just could have spoken to Dr. Deborah all day. If you don't currently have someone that feels like they're on your tribe, they're your community, as we discussed with Deborah, then why not let me be considered for that role for you? Why not let me welcome you into the Aspiring Psychologist membership. We are doing great things in there and people are finding it to be really supportive in, you know, compassionately encouraging their development, but also helping to develop their skills too. Got loads in there. So you can find out more information about that by clicking the link in the show notes
哦，谢谢你的收听或观看。如果你在YouTube上，我真想和黛博拉博士聊上一整天。如果你目前还没有感觉像是你的部落、你的社区的人，正如我们和黛博拉讨论的那样，那么为什么不让我为你担任那个角色呢？为什么不让我欢迎你加入“有抱负的心理学家”会员计划？我们在那里做着伟大的事情，人们发现它非常有支持力，你知道，在富有同情心地鼓励他们的发展，同时也帮助发展他们的技能。里面有很多内容。所以你可以通过点击节目说明中的链接找到更多信息
or my bio in any of my social media platforms will take you right there too and of course the clinical psychologist collective is also a great place to start if you're looking to broaden your narratives of people heading towards qualified roots in psychology thank you very much for being part of my world and don't forget the next episode of the aspiring psychologist podcast will be dropping into your ears um at 6 a.m on monday take care of you be kind if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide with this podcast at your side you to be on your way to being qualified
或者我任何社交媒体平台上的个人简介也会直接带你到那里。当然，如果你正在寻找拓宽心理学合格道路的叙事，临床心理学家集体也是一个很好的起点。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分，别忘了“有抱负的心理学家”播客的下一集将于周一早上6点准时送达你的耳边。照顾好自己，保持善良。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那么让这成为你的指南，有这个播客在你身边，你就能走上成为合格心理学家的道路。
It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Marianne Trent My name's Yana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I I'd definitely recommend
这是“有抱负的心理学家”播客，我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。我叫亚娜，我是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。各种不同的途径让我感到惊讶，没有完美的途径可以成为一名心理学家，这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐
this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这本书，它会让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。